happy birthday my friend before you
thanks for coming out to help me
celebrate tonight we thought it'd be fun
since it does fall actually on my
birthday Tonight Show that would be fun
to have like a birthday party with
everybody and you guys are cool for
coming out thank you can't be birthday
without cake though so I I took the
liberty of making sure that we got some
cake can we bring out the cake for young
master Garmin asleep there is booze and
cake yes and buckets and
[Applause]
really really
[Applause]
what's wrong with you
welcome to Hollywood put a dick in your
mouth now hold on hold on let's
appreciate this [ __ ] look it I
told them that your balls are very big
uh-huh
so they gave you big balls look at the
cream face white frosting coming out of
the tip and it's running down on to the
to the balls cutting it like you've
never seen one before I shaved my balls
so the pubes are right out of line I
don't know if I can eat this yeah
is this like Liam Neeson's kicker is
this that's meant to be you now it's a
bozo am I gonna eat this and you're
gonna take a bunch of pictures and the
rest of my life it's gonna be me like
putting my mouth on a [ __ ] and it's
gonna be on my IMDB page it's gonna CD
and everything yes dude so I'm what I'm
gonna do is shoot video and you know way
I can eat this I'm not looking for just
the tip Ralph that's it that's all I'm
looking for not an idiot I know these
these video and photos will haunt me
forever yeah but in the best way no all
right so it's Robertson way it's Ralph's
birthday this is Ralph's birthday cake
there is a Ralph's birthday friend my
birthday friend
[Applause]
and so since there's no candle because
it'd be cruel to stick a candle in that
cake we have to observe our own birthday
tradition and what I'm saying is you
just engulfed you do what we do on
Hollywood babble-on welcome to Hollywood
put a dick in your mouth man your
mistake was giving me the cake on my
first beer you should have waited till I
was like 6 or 7 tip all we need is just
the tip man here we go looks like
somebody took a bite out of it what
happened I don't know what happened
there what happened there it had a
little is little [ __ ] well said some
heavy petting that's what I was getting
all right here we go man do it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if they all taste like that I'm in
[Music]
you
[Music]